CLEVE MOLER: Hello.
I'm Cleve Moler,
one of the founders
and chief mathematician
at the MathWorks.
This series of videos is about
solving ordinary differential
equations in MATLAB.
We can begin by recalling
the definition of derivative.
The derivative of a
function at a point
is the slope of the
tangent line to the graph
of the function at that point.
Our numerical
approximations will
rely upon the slope of
the secant to the graph.
That's a line through two points
separated by a distance h.
We'll have a lot to say about
the step size h as we go along.
What's important to realize
is that as h goes to 0,
the slope of the
secant approaches
the slope of tangent.
The wiggly equals sign means
approximately equal to.
T0 is the point where we are
finding the approximation.
The value of the
derivative at t0
is approximately equal to
the slope of the secant.
The slope of the
secant is the change
in the y value over the
change in the t value.
The change in y value
is the difference
between the two values of y.
The change in the t
value is the step size h.
If we rewrite this,
we get the value of y
at the point t0 plus
h is approximately
equal to the value of
y at t0 plus h times
the value of y prime at t0.
This is the basis for our
first numerical method,
Euler's method.
Leonhard Euler was a 18th
century Swiss mathematician.
Probably the most influential
mathematician of his era.
He made important
contributions to a wide range
of fields of mathematics,
physics, and astronomy.
He invented the notion of
a function, for example.
The differential equation
is given by this function
f of two variables t and y.
And the task in general
is to find the function y
whose derivative is equal to f.
Now, there's lots of functions y
And so there's an initial
condition, a point t
naught or t0, and a value y0.
And the initial
condition is that y at t0
should be equal to y0.
Here's some examples.
The compound interest problem is
just the interest rate times y.
Here, the function of t and y
doesn't actually depend upon t.
And it's linear in y.
The initial condition
is at time 0,
there's a specified
value of y, like $100.
That's the compound
interest problem.
Here's the logistic equation.
Nonlinear equation.
Here, f of t and y, again,
doesn't depend upon t.
And it's a constant times y
minus another constant times
y squared.
That's the logistic equation.
And again, the value
is specified at 0.
Let's say y at 0 is equal to 1.
Here's another
nonlinear equation.
F of t and y is t
squared plus y squared.
It's not possible to
find an analytic solution
to this equation.
We'll use these numerical
methods to find a solution
to this equation.
Initial condition y
at 0 is equal to 0.
That's an example of
a function of t and y.
Euler's method actually isn't
a practical numerical method
in general.
We're just using it
to get us started
thinking about the ideas
underlying numerical methods.
Euler's method involves
a sequence of points
t sub n separated by
a fixed step size h.
And then y sub n is an
approximation to the value
of the solution at t sub n.
The approximation comes from
the slope of the secant.
The ratio of the difference
of the values of y
and to the step size h.
The differential equation
says that this ratio
should be the value of
the function at t sub n.
And if we rearrange
this equation,
we get Euler's method.
That yn plus 1 is yn plus
h times the function f
evaluated at t
sub n and y sub n.
This is Euler's method.
We're now ready for our
first MATLAB program, ODE1.
It's called ODE1 because
it's our first program
and because it
evaluates the function f
that defines the differential
equation once per step.
There are five input arguments.
The first is f, a function
that defines the differential
equation.
This is something called
an anonymous function.
I'll talk more about
that in a moment.
The other four are
scalar numerical values.
The first three define the
interval of integration.
We're going from t0 in
steps of h to t final.
The fifth input argument
is y0, the initial value.
The output is a vector.
Vector y out is the
values of the solution
at the points in the interval.
We start by putting y0,
the initial value, into y
and then putting y
into the output vector.
The body of the
function is a four loop,
t goes from T0 not in steps of H
up to one step short of t final
and then the final passage
through the body of the code
takes t up to t final.
We evaluate the
function f at t and y.
That gives us a slope
s, s is for slope.
Here's the Euler step.
Take the current value of
y, add h, times the slope.
That gives us this
new value of y.
And then y is appended to y out.
This MATLAB construction
with the square brackets
takes a vector y, adds
another value to it,
making it one element longer
and puts the resulting y out
back in y out.
This is the entire code.
This is it.
This is ODE1 that
implements Euler's method.
The first argument to any
of the MATLAB ODE solvers
is the name of a function that
specifies the differential
equation.
This is known as
a function handle.
The easiest way to
get a function handle
is to make use of an
anonymous function created
with the ampersand or at sign.
All of the
differential equations
involve anonymous functions
of two variables, t and y.
And so we have f equals
at parenthesis t comma y
closed parenthesis.
This is followed by any
expression involving
either t or y.
And many of them
don't depend upon t.
So here is an anonymous function
defining our interest problem.
And we can just evaluate this
like any ordinary function.
When y is equal to
1, f of 1 is 0.06.
Here's an example of a function
that depends upon both t and y.
The functions can involve
constants that have values.
So here, we can
define two constants.
And then we can use
those two constants
to define the logistic
equation f of a times
y minus b times y squared.
Again, this is an autonomous
equation that doesn't actually
depend upon t.
Let's see how Euler's
method and ODE1
work on this simple example.
Y prime equals 2y with the
initial condition y of 0
equals 10 on the interval
t between 0 and 3.
We define the anonymous function
f of t and y is equal to 2y.
The initial condition
is t0 equals 0.
We're going to take
a step size of 1.
Go to t final equals
3 starting at y0
equals 10 and here's
our call to ODE1.
We have an animation
that shows these steps.
Start at t0 equals
0 and y0 equals 10.
Here's our first point.
We evaluate the function there.
We get a slope of 20.
That's 2 times 10.
We take an Euler step of
length 1 across the first step.
That brings us to
the second point, 30.
Evaluate the function there.
Two times 30 is 60.
That's our slope.
Take the second
step to get to y2.
Y2 is 90.
Evaluate the function there.
Get 2 times 90 is 180.
That gives us a slope.
Take a step across the
interval with that slope
would get us to a third point.
The third point
is 270 and that's
the end of the integration.
So that's three Euler steps
to get from t0 to t final.
Euler's method is
actually the same
as computing compound interest.
So let's do a compound
interest problem.
Define the interest rate.
Define our anonymous function
using that interest rate.
Start at time 0.
Go in steps of a month.
Go for 10 years.
Start with $100.
And here's our
result of using ODE1
to compute compound interest.
That's 121 numbers.
MATLAB actually has a format for
looking at dollars and cents.
And so here they are as dollars
and cents starting with $100
and compounding every month.
We get up to just over $180.
I'm going to plot that.
So I want a time vector months.
And I actually want to compare
it with simple interest.
So here's how you
compute simple interest.
$0.50 a month.
And now let's plot those two.
So the straight line is simple
interest getting up to $160.
And the blue line is
the compound interest.
There is a slight
upward curvature,
getting us up to $180.
There's a dot every
month here as we
show the results of Euler's
method, which as I said
is the same thing as
computing compound interest.
Finally, here's an exercise.
Find the differential equation
that produces linear growth
and rerun this example
using ODE1 twice,
once to compute the
compound interest
and once to compute
the simple interest.